boy these guys are decent before we
start I want to show you my gaming setup
I like to sit square with a television
set a lot of people ask if I PC I don't
I don't even own a PC so I play my games
on ps4 I used to use that little
microphone that came and I couldn't hear
my friends so I got myself a decent
headset here the HyperX wireless I can
hear clearly not just what my friends
are saying but also 360 audio hashtag
not sponsoring I got the Herman Miller
and body chair a few years ago because I
knew I was going to be doing a lot of
notes it's probably the worst part about
being a doctor but it also doubles as an
excellent gaming chair unlike most
chairs this is super flexible it
basically has like a human spine on it
it has really good breathability it's
based on coils how about we play some
apex are you ready cuz I'm ready let's
go I know you may think that I play a
character like lifeline because I'm a
doctor but I like to cause some havoc so
I play octane I actually like octane and
Bangalore I'm very aggressive in this
game as you will see probably more
aggressive than need beat if a pro
watches me they'll probably laugh at how
bad I am at this game but you know after
all this isn't my day job so I think
that's okay I have a tough time playing
against Pathfinder and caustic those are
probably my two most painted with blood
characters path fighter I feel like it's
hitboxes are all messed up obviously
this video has nothing to do about
medicine so get ready for a wild ride
where you're gonna see a doctor dominate
I mean I guess it depends on my team
members but for all those people they're
like why don't you just play Forte well
for at night the building I'm too old
for that I can't learn how to build I
can shoot I can use the sticks
that's it some strategy building come on
down and I play this game really
strategically I feel like I'm in the
military and I play this game so I like
to see who's dropping where where the
ship is going look no one's going here
good well that was cool how do you do
that I'm gonna wrap around this mouth
but I like to be quick just pick up
whatever is in yeah Oh purple helmet I'm
gonna let these guys get all that stuff
and hopefully it'll be a shield here I'm
always gonna take a peek and make sure
no one's coming from the other side and
you'll notice that I pick up all the
guns right away
the reason I do that is because I don't
want my enemies picking doesn't look
like there's anyone on the other side
right across thank you I don't need that
shotguns used to be really good at this
game but I think this season they've
kind of fallen off oh I'll take that
most definitely uh-oh Spitfire do you
want that No okay I'll take it oh he
just took it right out from me I like
playing octane cuz I feel like I could
just run around the Commedia
ooh longbow here let's go for the
longbow Oh
our boy just went that let's go get our
I don't think I can fight that
headshots Oh who is shooting me this is
like my decompression to be honest this
is this is how I decompress your call
where you want to drop pimp oh I guess
it's Michael got him let's go to kill
box Oh
ah why is it always the worst timing in
this game there's a lifeline I tried I
tried my very best mom I'm gonna hide
cuz I hear people
I'll hear
are you getting shopping Ono wow that
was close
guy I need help down here
Oh gimme a shot I got him right here
come on yo come on what is going on I'm
trying to put work in and my guys
literally sleeping on me
I'm giving you guys fire fights no just
watching me Luke dude I'm gonna try and
help you that's what I'm talking about
baby yeah baby let's go
gotta hide I'm so scared
I can't leave I'm fighting this by
myself the struggles of playing on your
own
oh come on man I can't take on the
entire game I just saw a shadow fly by
me I'm like it's not my shadow
definitely not much had a migraine all
day still play an apex
ah
right I think they're coming up
maybe not
[Applause]
good good good fence
bring up moving now
ah
I've never outlast it like that yes
because this guy helped me out but we
did it as a team of the left so I'm
talking about baby we got one win let's
open some apex pecs pecs apex packs this
is fun I always like to see what stuff I
get crafting metals that's big okay
let's see what the next for this
actually I want to get a new skin for
octane but I feel like I'm behind on
that let's see if I have enough metals
for it Diablo Diablo oh I like speed
demon - oh man I like all of these I
think Gold Rush is probably like the
most hitting one even though that's the
one I like least Oh Java looks bad
let's see Gold Rush 1200 oh I'm gonna
craft it with you guys damn crafting
look at that haha cool now let's play
one with the gold skin god I can't
believe it's making me play by myself
that's so messed up I feel like it
should like not take away our P points
and thanks for telling me I'm jump
master when I'm playing by myself
see at this point I just like to bother
them let them know that I'm watching
them whoa come on these guys are
sharpshooters right now I was just
trying to bother them a little bit okay
[Applause]
yeah baby let's go
machines
guys come on they're all low they're all
low
why is my teammate shooting you is he
like teasing me I think he's gonna stop
oh come on man ah I'm diggin apex
legends right now I know it's not very
medically accurate but it's still a
whole lot of fun and it's something I do
on my spare time and I want to share
that with you guys if you want to see me
play overwatch pictionary weird medical
games click here for my let's play
playlist and have a blast as always stay
happy and healthy
[Music]